[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
les Bleus qualifiés pour la quatrième
finale de leur histoire la deuxième de
suite ils vont affronter vous le savez
l'Argentine Mbappé Messi quelle affiche
les Bleus sont-ils en route pour une
troisième étoile et bien on va en parler
ce soir à poser la question à mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés sylvert-henri si c'est bonsoir
journaliste et consultant en sport
international membre du conseil
scientifique sport histoire et
citoyenneté pour Paris 2024
Jean-Baptiste Guégan est avec nous
bonsoir enseignant et spécialistes en
géopolitique du sport co-auteur de la
République du foot aux éditions en forêt
et puis également de l'Atlas
géopolitique du sport aux éditions
Autrement nous avons avec nous Cédric
Ferreira notre envoyé spécial au Qatar
bonsoir Cédric
bonsoir et puis nous attendons donc un
quatrième invité bonsoir bonsoir Mickaël
Madar qui est en ancien joueur du PSG
qui devrait donc nous rejoindre après
Saint-Denis Munich Saint-Pétersbourg il
y a donc désormais ICOR l'équipe de
France qualifiée pour sa quatrième
finale de Coupe du monde en 24 ans s'il
gagne dimanche ils vont rejoindre dans
l'histoire du foot l'Italie et le Brésil
seul seul pays à avoir remporté
successivement deux trophées mondiaux
Emmanuel Macron était présent à la
demi-finale hier au Qatar on l'écoute
on est très fiers immensément fier et je
pense que nos compatriotes ont besoin de
voilà de joie simple et pure le sport en
procure le foot tout particulièrement
donc moi je suis beaucoup mieux
maintenant que il y a une heure et demie
les Marocains ont formidablement bien
joué et je pense que le match était pas
le même si égalisés on a vu beaucoup de
cœur on a on a parfois souffert mais on
a vu une très grande équipe voilà et moi
je veux le dire un immense merci à notre
sélectionneur guidée Deschamps et en
fait à cette équipe qui est un mélange
de plusieurs générations et c'est ça qui
est formidable Cédric je démarre avec
vous puisque vous êtes sur place au
Qatar la France a-t-elle rendez-vous
dimanche avec la légende si elle gagne
évidemment vous venez de rappeler le
fait que dans l'histoire très peu
d'équipes ont réussi à conserver leur
titre mondial et c'est vrai que ce
France Argentine est quand même une
affiche de rêve d'un côté il y a Lionel
Messi qui va disputer probablement sa
dernière Coupe du monde à 35 ans le sol
trop fait majeur qui lui manque et puis
en face du côté des bleus il y a
peut-être son successeur celui qui
appelait à dominer le football mondial
dans les années à venir Kylian Mbappé
alors lui il a déjà remporté la Coupe du
monde en 2018 mais le style signait déjà
un doublé alors qu'il n'a que 23 ans
assurément il rentrerait tout de suite
dans la légende du football Sylvère vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
Cédric ils peuvent écrire l'histoire
dimanche
le football mondial aujourd'hui c'est
pas assurément et que Messi est juste en
dessous parce qu'il est sur le déclin
Mbappé aujourd'hui et le joueur star
c'est un peu le pelu de l'époque des
années 58 62 quand pellet a remporté les
deux Coupes du Monde d'affilée et moi ce
que je souhaite c'est vraiment qui
puisse remporter cette du monde pour qui
lui déjà rentre dans cette histoire là
qu'il inscrivent son nom avec deux
Coupes du Monde d'affilée qui sera
remporté par ce joueur et si ce joueur
le remporte c'est l'équipe de France
c'est-à-dire que l'équipe de France va
remporter deux Coupes du Monde d'affilée
je vous l'ai déjà dit Stéphanie ce qui
est important à travers ce cette
victoire c'est bien sûr l'équipe de
France mais c'est aussi c'est tout le
football français et je voudrais qu'on
prenne le temps aussi de parler qu'on
parle de tout ce que le football
français représente sur ces 20 dernières
années pour parvenir
en 2018 et peut-être je l'espère en tout
cas dimanche une deuxième défilé
Jean-Baptiste Guégan alors on a vu
Emmanuel Macron évoquer la fierté il
aurait dû boycotter le match Emmanuel
Macron vous êtes face à un président de
la République qui est dans son exercice
dans son rôle il représente la France il
va au soutien des équipes de France et
en l'occurrence il est dans son rôle a
fortiori vous êtes chez un partenaire
stratégique le Qatar en plus face à une
équipe rock effectivement le fait que ne
respecte pas les droits humains enfin
tout ce qu'on a pu d'ailleurs dénoncé
contre le Qatar on peut avoir un
discours construit mais la logique pose
un problème c'est que vous ne
construisez pas de relation avec l'autre
or vous ne pouvez pas lui demander de
changer ou l'amener à changer si vous le
snober ou si justement vous l'évitez là
l'intérêt c'est d'avoir un discours qui
va être ferme un discours qui va être
franc et un discours qui va être aussi
marqué par rapport de force ça c'est
possible si vous n'êtes pas là ce
discours là vous l'avez pas rien de
change on appelle ça une posture
médiatique
la négociation implique en tout cas que
l'on puisse rencontrer les gens à
distance est très difficile on les
prouve tous dans nos réunions quand on
est à distance en télétravail c'est très
difficile parce que il y a la visio
conférence qui me permet pas de faire
passer certains sentiments le fait de
pouvoir se rencontrer c'est pouvoir
poser la main sur la main sur le bras de
l'interlocuteur c'est pouvoir regarder
dans les yeux sentir son souffle c'est
le non-verbal c'est plein de choses qui
participent à négociation et là il va
profiter de quoi de cette occasion pour
rencontrer déjà les dirigeants qatari et
pas que les autres les dirigeants qatari
parce qu'il y a plein d'autres occasions
aussi pour discuter avec des dirigeants
qui sont Michael Madar vous nous avez
rejoint si un joueur du PSG journal et
consultant sur Canal+ merci d'être avec
nous ce soir un mot est-ce que la France
a rendez-vous avec la légende dimanche
c'est la question que je venais de poser
à nos invités
[Musique]
en train de faire là à l'heure actuelle
c'est quand même assez assez incroyable
en 4 ans jouer deux finales de Coupe du
monde en ayant gagné une déjà je trouve
que ouais ils peuvent rentrer dans la
légende facilement oui un mot sur le
match face au Maroc l'équipe de France a
dominé ce Maroc sans jouer sa meilleure
partition c'est comme ça que vous
pourriez l'analyser aussi le verre oui
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
effectivement ça a pas été une grande
équipe de France mais ce que je trouve
vraiment très chouette c'est que une
France une équipe de France qui est en
fait dans la maîtrise c'est une équipe
de France qui s'est jamais
désolidarisé qui s'est jamais affolée
vous savez avec Didier Deschamps et avec
l'expérience maintenant ils ont ce petit
truc en plus qu'ils disent on peut pas
nous battre et on va y arriver parce
qu'on est dans la maîtrise n'existe la
défaite n'existe pas et même quand il y
a des petits coups d'affolement la vue
il y a un aurait pu paniquer mais non
ils sont toujours restés dans le
contrôle c'est une équipe qui est
vraiment solide mentalement physiquement
et techniquement c'est à dire que même
quand il y a des petits coups de mou
comme hier soir c'était pas un grand
match sauf que Mbappé par deux fois à
apporter les éclairs de génie c'est
largement suffisant pour gagner avec
comme je vous l'ai dit un Griezmann qui
a été mais alors lui mais aujourd'hui
c'est un coffre-fort d'ailleurs que pour
moi c'est la star de cette équipe bien
avant de notre-dessus de Mbappé je crois
qu'il faut jeter un copropriétaire sur
Griezmann parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
pivot c'est la clé de cette équipe
Cédric puisque vous avez assisté au
match en live ou sur place est-ce que il
y a eu un triomphe modeste face au Maroc
de la part des Bleus
un triomphe modeste oui on peut dire ça
quand même parce que
Silver vient de le dire c'est vrai que
globalement l'équipe de France a
maîtrisé n'a pas paniqué dans les
moments chauds maintenant on attendait
peut-être un peu plus de l'équipe de
France dans notre côté il faut quand
même être on va dire ne pas être trop
exigeant avec cette équipe puisque le
Maroc a joué la partition qu'on
attendait c'est-à-dire rester surtout en
défense alors le plan du sélectionneur
relais de n'a pas du tout marché en
début de rencontre avec ce but encaissé
de la cinquième minute qui est
intéressant de voir avec l'équipe de
France en fait c'est que elle est
capable de s'adapter au scénario aux
différents scénarios des rencontres aux
différents adversaires également puisque
là contrairement au rencontre passé dans
ce tournoi la plupart des rencontres
passées l'équipe de France n'a pas eu la
possession du ballon alors il y a des
statistiques qui sont sortis ensuite en
montrant que sous l'air Didier Deschamps
en Coupe du monde quand l'équipe de
France n'a pas la possession du ballon
en général ça se finit par une victoire
donc faut aussi donner tout le crédit à
Didier Deschamps il y a la prestation
des joueurs Griezmann surtout qui est
qui vraiment sort du lot dans ce tournoi
mais il y a aussi Didier Deschamps qui
même avec tous les absents on peut
revenir même encore avant la Coupe du
monde sans Golo Kanté son Paul Pogba là
c'était Adrien rabiot qui était
étincelant aussi depuis le début de
cette Coupe du Monde qui était absent
malgré tous ces tous ces déboires pour
le sélectionneur il arrive à construire
chaque fois une équipe cohérente et qui
reste maître de son destin du début
jusqu'à la fin de la rencontre Mickaël
madame Griezmann il était quoi impérial
chef d'orchestre altruiste moi j'ai lu
tout ça aujourd'hui le sens du devoir
c'est un peu tout ça mais bon après on
savait très bien que
c'est quand même un leader de cette
équipe de France on l'avait un peu
oublié vu les déboires qu'il a pu qu'il
a pu connaître avec avec le Barça et
avec la Pico de Madrid qui lui
permettait pas de jouer en début de
saison donc voilà on retrouve un
Griezmann en pleine forme maintenant moi
je suis pas je suis pas je suis pas
vraiment étonné mais bon après c'est pas
le seul il faut quand même mettre aussi
Hugo Loris dans dans les leaders ou
vraiment qui nous a sorti quand même
quelques épines du pied depuis le début
de cette Coupe du monde après je
voudrais juste dire une chose je
t’intéresse du genre j'entendais parler
de maîtrise moi j'ai pas trouvé vraiment
cette équipe de France maîtriser son
sujet bien au contraire j'ai trouvé qu'à
certains moments on était un peu dépassé
par par les événements et je pense que
l'expérience a fait a fait la différence
mais depuis le début de cette Coupe du
Monde
c'est pas pour dévaloriser ce qui a fait
l'équipe de France mais on n'a pas
rencontré grand monde quoi depuis le
début de l'année depuis le début de la
cette compétition pardon donc voilà je
trouve que
c'est un peu c'est un peu compliqué à
chaque fois c'est très difficile à
supporter en tant que
téléspectateurs et supporters l'équipe
de France comme hier soir c'était assez
tendu pour vous c'était difficile à
supporter moi je prends ça je pense à
hacker moi donc c'est vrai
on était toujours
on n'était pas à l'abri d'une erreur
quoi c'était c'était le problème mais
bon on s'en est sorti quand même c'est
le principal Jean-Baptiste Guégan moi je
pense aussi hier
jusqu'à la quatrième minute et après on
joue c'est un mix cette équipe entre
l'Italie des années 90 c'est l'Allemagne
des années 70-80 c'est-à-dire que il y a
une instabilité créatrice vous subissez
mais vous avez l'impression qu'il ne
peut rien vous arriver que tout va dans
votre sens ces matchs là il y a 20 ans
les perdait aujourd'hui on les gagne et
pire que ça on est dominé on accepte
cette domination et on en fait une force
on contre il y a un petit côté presque
Mohamed Ali c'est à dire que j'encaisse
j'encaisse et au moment où je frappe je
suis décisif c'est exactement ça c'est
pour ça que je parlais de maîtrise quand
je parle de maîtrise c'est la maîtrise
déjà mentale sur le terrain c'est à dire
que on a on a affaire à une équipe qui
est excellente du Maroc qui était
physiquement diminué par toutes les
rencontres mais effectivement avec
l'assurance que on a la capacité à
pouvoir résister c'est là où je parle de
maîtrise que d'autres équipes dans les
mêmes conditions auraient pu exploser
aurait pu tout simplement perdre pieds
et l'équipe de France avec son
expérience et bien la tenue c'est ça qui
est intéressant je suis peut-être amour
encore du Maroc avec peut-être la
dignité donc de Walid le sélectionneur
qui finalement a dit le plus important
c'était d'avoir montré au monde que le
football marocain existait j'espère que
la France va gagner donc il est beau
joueur oui parce que vous savez il est
né en France je crois il est d'accord
donc il a ce ce cœur qui est à moitié
marocain il y a moitié français et il
sera à coup sûr pour l'équipe de France
contre l'Argentine et ça c'est vraiment
très très chouette vous savez ça
correspond à quoi ça correspond aussi à
toute l'Afrique on a dit l'Afrique est
avec le Maroc ce qui est tout à fait
normal parce qu'il y a une forme de de
fraternité de continents mais ce que je
peux vous assurer c'est que l'équipe de
France elle a une cote de sympathie
énorme sur le continent africain et que
dimanche c'est toute l'Afrique je pense
la grande majorité de l'Afrique qui sera
avec l'équipe de France c'est vrai que
vous êtes d'accord vous qui êtes sur
place parce qu'on peut dire que toute
l'Afrique était plutôt derrière le Maroc
pendant ce match France - Maroc est-ce
que est-ce que dimanche ils seront
derrière la France
ici sur place ça sera beaucoup plus
partagé parce qu'il y a déjà énormément
de supporters argentin donc déjà je peux
vous assurer que le stade de Bruxelles
qui va accueillir la finale sera en
grande partie bleue et ciel après de
bulles depuis le début du tournoi
effectivement tous les pays africains et
tous les pays arabes ont une côte de
popularité énorme ici et ça a été donc
le cas avec le Maroc qui a été le
dernier représentant ici c'est clair à
Doha mais également quand on parlait
avec les ressortissants des pays voisins
tout le monde était absolument derrière
le Maroc pour battre la France parce que
et à cette histoire de dernier pays
africains il y a cette histoire de de
pays arabes qui représente aussi les
voisins de manière générale dans ce
tournoi les équipes qui ont été le plus
soutenues de mémoire en tout cas dans
les stades c'est le Maroc l'Arabie
Saoudite également qui était lors de la
phase de groupe tout le stade était vert
c'était vraiment très impressionnant de
voir les supporters saoudiens déchaînés
là pour la pour l'équipe pour la fête
finale entre la France et l'Argentine
le soutien ne sera pas aussi clair en
faveur de l'équipe de France
Michael Madar le foot français est
possédé par la force de l'habitude j'ai
lu ça dans le monde vous êtes d'accord
avec ça la force de l'habitude
oui oui maintenant on commence ouais de
gagner oui bien sûr
on n'avait pas il y a une mue du foot
français
il y a eu une mue du foot français
peut-être après cette Champions League a
gagné Marseille
voilà c'est si je pense a été un déclic
pour le pour le foot français et on a
commencé à avoir cette habitude de la
gagne et d'avoir cette mentalité surtout
ce qu'on n'avait pas avant on partait un
peu un peu perdant souvent et maintenant
on a repris le slogan que on donnait
avant aux Allemands que à partir du
moment où il rentrait sur le terrain
c'était gagné maintenant c'est la France
qui qui a qui a donc cette ce slogan
quoi donc voilà c'est vrai qu'on a on a
énormément progressé à ce niveau là je
pense aussi que le fait d'avoir d'avoir
joué d'avoir des joueurs qui qui
évoluent dans des clubs étrangers et
surtout par exemple en Italie à une
certaine époque qui ont cette culture de
la gagne
ont réussi à la remettre au service du
football français donc je pense que
c'est dû à ça c'est mon avis il y a un
homme clé en tout cas c'est Didier
Deschamps on va voir son portrait
derrière cette ambiance un homme Didier
Deschamps l'architecte de l'équipe de
France en menant les Bleus à une
nouvelle finale d'un Mondial Didier
Deschamps de son empreinte le foot
français
il est au top et super sélectionnant
donc on est tous avec lui pour pour la
finale et j'espère qu'on va gagner la
troisième étoile si l'équipe de France
s'impose dimanche contre l'Argentine
Didier Deschamps deviendrait le seul
homme à avoir remporté une coupe du
monde en tant que joueur et de en tant
qu'entraîneur son palmarès parle de
lui-même il est le joueur international
le plus capé en tant que capitaine des
Bleus il a remporté la Coupe du monde en
1998 et l'euro en 2000 avant de hisser
l'équipe de France sur le toit du monde
en 2018 en tant qu'entraîneur et de
remporter la Ligue des Nations l'année
dernière
malgré tout l'homme reste humble et
refuse de se mettre en avant
même dans les périodes difficiles c'est
toujours enfin moi en tant qu'entraîneur
sélectionné
c'est surtout la satisfaction et la
fierté par rapport au groupe de joueurs
qui sont là je pense pas spécialement à
moi même si j'apprécie aussi mais c'est
surtout c'est surtout pour pour eux
Didier Deschamps a été nommé en 2012 il
hérite alors d'une situation
catastrophique après le Mondial
désastreux de Nice na et un Euro 2012
insipide match après match il rebâtit
l'équipe de France et permet au bleu
d'atteindre la finale de l'Euro 2016 à
domicile l'une de ses principales forces
gérer les égaux des joueurs et créés un
esprit d'équipe le contrat de Didier
Deschamps se termine à la fin de l'année
mais selon la presse il pourrait être
prolongé jusqu'en 2024
DRH de haut niveau Didier Deschamps
Silvers
qui l'a vu en tant que joueur en tant
que entraîneur mais aussi la manière
dont il a su préserver cette équipe je
pense qu'il y a un tournant c'est le
franc suisse à l'euro cette équipe de
France elle aurait pu exploser avec les
égaux et la manière dont l'élimination a
été gérée il a su reprendre cette équipe
en main et surtout il a su se remettre
en cause je pense qu'il a changé lui
aussi à ce moment-là il avait un côté
qui était très rigide un peu sergent
recruteur dans Fullmetal jacket oui
vraiment vraiment il avait ce côté là
vous savez très rigide très militaire
moi qui suffisent de militaires je bois
un peu de quelle manière il dirigeait
ses joueurs et il a un tout petit peu
changé il s'est assoupli il a il a
établi un autre contact avec ses joueurs
et ce qui amène aussi à ce résultat là
c'est à dire que le groupe il est
totalement complet et c'est plus qu'un
sélectionneur aussi je pense qu'il a ce
côté un peu paternel avec ses joueurs
qui est très intéressant qui vient de se
confier et vous savez que quand vous
avez des égaux qui sont très très élevés
dans le monde du foot professionnel
dans un vestiaire il faut quelqu'un qui
est le palmarès de de Deschamps pour
pouvoir les gérer parce qu'à un moment
Didier Deschamps de manière très simple
il va dire j'ai tout gagné donc
écoute-moi voilà ce qui va dire à ses
joueurs donc il va attirer le respect
aussi parce qu'il a représenté en tant
que joueur et ce qu'il a représenté
aussi en tant que entraîneur Cédric
Cédric
oui je veux rebondir sur je veux
rebondir sur ce que disait Sylvain Henry
il a raison d'insister sur ce point
puisque durant ce Mondial il y a
plusieurs joueurs qui ont évoqué ce
rapport avec Didier Deschamps et
notamment Adrien rabiot vous souvenez
qu'il avait refusé de faire partie des
réservistes pour le dernier Mondial on
imaginait peut-être sa carrière en
équipe de France terminée sous Didier
Deschamps en tout cas ça c'était avec
l'ancien Didier Deschamps et c'est vrai
qu'il a assoupli sa position et
notamment dans ce rapport avec ses
joueurs et Adrien rabiot la confié
durant le tournoi en conférence de
presse où il expliquait et bien qu'il a
senti que son rapport avec Didier
Deschamps a évolué dans le bon sens et
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui explique
ses performances avec les Bleus car elle
avait été plutôt décevante de manière
générale en équipe de France et sur ce
mondiale et le rayonne vraiment il
rayonne vraiment vous êtes d'accord
ouais et rayonne parce que je pense
qu'il a il a adopté un management de
proximité on est vraiment il est dans le
contact avec les gens il est touché pas
avant aujourd'hui vous le voyez faire et
il s'est adapté aussi à la demande de
cette génération qui a besoin en plus de
son talent d'être approché cajolé en
tout cas
rassurer aussi émotionnellement est-ce
qu'on voit là c'est que c'est peut-être
la plus belle muse elle a laquelle on
s'attendait pas c'est celle de quelqu'un
qui a gagné à la dure qui a toujours été
talentueux mais qui a tout eu finalement
par le travail et qu'il a compris qu'il
fallait accompagner et il y a aussi
laissé la clé aux joueurs parce que voir
le retour de Karim Benzema certes plus
là mais une équipe très jeune aussi
parce que les nouveaux arrivants ils ont
moins de 25 ans et ça c'était pas
c'était pas concevable avant cet équip
là elle fait plaisir à voir parce que
justement le sélectionneur a
complètement aussi modifié sa manière de
voir les choses même de communiquer
Michael Madar vous êtes d'accord
je rejoins tout ce qui a été dit avant
voilà moi je connais un peu
personnellement donc j'ai eu l'occasion
d'évoluer avec lui oui c'est sûr qu'il a
dû évoluer avec avec les nouvelles
générations il a pas eu le choix et
c'est vrai que maintenant il a il a un
certain comportement avec avec ses
joueurs qui qui n'avait qui n'avait pas
avant maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un peu le papa c'est un peu le
copain
mais en même temps il arrive à mettre
des limites et à être respecté et ses
joueurs je pense que comme le disait
silver il a un palmarès il parle pour
lui et il peut il peut parler aux
joueurs en connaissance de cause et ça
c'est quand même c'est quand même une
force que d'autres entraîneurs ne
peuvent pas non pas quoi voilà
son contrat se termine à la fin de
l'année oui alors j'entends dire ici et
là que il pourra plus rien faire après
si jamais il remporte la Coupe du Monde
moi j'y crois pas un seul instant s'il
gagne la Coupe du Monde et bien il
continuera parce qu'il a attendez juste
il a le meilleur job au monde c'est
juste fantastique d'être sélectionneur
d'une équipe comme celle-ci
c'est à dire qu'on travaille à peu près
quoi sur le plan effectivement 2 à 3
mois par an le reste du temps on
regardait match on bouffe du football on
voyage on voit la rencontre des joueurs
on est dans des moments exceptionnels
comme une coupe du monde un championnat
d'Europe on vit des moments qui sont
très rares pourquoi il arrêterait
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire après si ce
n'est continuer encore avec l'équipe de
France et continuer avec la génération
parce que vous savez en France on a des
jeunes qui sont derrière et qui stockent
à la porte de l'équipe de France qui
peuvent justement continuer encore cette
expérience c'est ce que l'on vit en ce
moment donc je ne vois pas arrêter et
surtout pour nous il faut surtout pas
qu'il arrête et il vaut mieux qu'ils
continuent en tout cas je l'espère
oui pour continuer le propos
effectivement on a raison de de parler
de l'avenir de Didier Deschamps puisque
c'est un compétiteur ça on le sait il
était en tant que joueur donc
sélectionneur et puis finalement le seul
trophée qui lui manque en tant que
sélectionneur en tout cas majeur c'est
le championnat d'Europe il l'a jamais
gagné avec les Bleus donc on peut très
bien l'imaginer continuer il y a aussi
ce réservoir de joueurs que vous avez
souligné on parle quand même d'une
équipe de France où il y a peut-être 4-5
titulaires qui sont blessés qui ne sont
pas dans ce Mondial quelle sélection au
monde peut prétendre être en finale de
Coupe du monde sans cinq joueurs majeurs
dans l'équipe de départ donc ça aussi
Didier Deschamps aura la matière en
temps dans la qualité de l'effectif pour
continuer et puis il y aura ce
championnat d'Europe aller chercher pour
lui pour compléter son palmarès
il y a une limite aussi et ça il faut la
prendre en compte c'est l'avenir du
président de la Fédération française de
football on sait qu'il y a une enquête
administrative dont on va avoir les
conclusions en janvier peut-être que
l'avenir de deschons il est aussi lié à
celui de Noël le Great et aujourd'hui sa
situation est plus instable
Michael Madar oui un mot là-dessus
peut-être
moi je pense que Noël de Grey veut le
faire signer impérativement à plus de
Coupe du Monde quelques années encore
donc à partir du moment où il a un
contrat donc on sera respecté et voilà
moi c'est en plus c'est un job qui lui
convient parfaitement quoi
dimanche la finale c'est France
Argentine bien sûr on le disait avec
donc l'affiche de l'affiche c'est Mbappé
Messi on va faire un point en images
avec ton confrère de France Télévisions
c'est une guerre des étoiles un duel au
sommet mais si contre Mbappé pour la
presse mondiale comme ici en Italie deux
rois face à face de roi difficile à
départager
les deux par rapport à sa carrière par
rapport à tout ça ce serait un peu une
insulte mais si de dire que elle m'a
appelé son égal mais si Mbappé deux
joueurs qui se côtoient depuis deux
saisons au PSG deux stars planétaires
réunies à deux moments différents de
leurs carrière
l'Argentin a 35 ans le français 23 ans
une jeunesse qui permet à Mbappé d'être
aujourd'hui mieux rémunéré mais la
longévité de Messi ce chiffre aussi au
nombre de ses fans 350 millions
Lionel Messi Kylian Mbappe c'est donc
aussi un duel de génération en club
comment sélection avec une obsession
écrire l'histoire
Messi c'est cette Ballon d'Or et un
palmarès en club hors norme avec entre
autres quatre ligues des champions avec
Barcelone son club de cœur mais Mbappe
c'est surtout une coupe du monde en 2018
au Qatar les supporters argentins que
nous avons rencontré ce matin ont aussi
leur idée sur ce duel
c'est une histoire d'héritage le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps
affronte son successeur
je crois que c'est l'année de Messi
c'est de là ce sont déjà affrontés en
2018 la France de Mbappe avait alors
éliminé l'Argentine de Messi en 8e de
finale dimanche soir l'attaquant de
l'équipe de France se verrait bien
décrocher sa deuxième Coupe du Monde
l'Argentin lui ne veut surtout pas
revivre les larmes de 2014 après la
finale perdu contre l'Allemagne son rêve
décrochait le seul trophée qui lui
manque alors Cédric
ah là c'est une question vraiment
difficile à trancher
la balance pour moi pense plutôt du côté
de l'équipe de France elle Mbappé qui
est qui est en pleine forme qui a la
jeunesse pour lui qui a les Bleus qui
sont montés en puissance dans ce tournoi
il y a pas toujours de la maîtrise c'est
vrai l'équipe de France souffre beaucoup
contre ces adversaires c'est vrai mais
il y a quand même beaucoup de confiance
et puis là ces joueurs comme Antoine
Griezmann intouchable au sommet du foot
mondial actuellement de l'autre côté à
cet Argentine quand même avec Lionel
Messi tout le pays c'est même plus c'est
une c'est même plus une question de
sélection de supporters c'est le pays
entier qui est derrière cette équipe et
qui veut voir Lionel Messi prendre la
succession de Diego Maradona en Coupe du
monde en soulevant ce trophée
l'Argentine on le rappelle avait très
mal commencé son tournoi avec justement
un match qu'elle n'avait pas du tout
maîtrisé contre l'Arabie Saoudite il y a
eu des changements tactiques de la part
d'entraîneur l'équipe est monté en
puissance après la confiance et
aujourd'hui elle se présente sur d'elle
face à l'équipe de France mais ça
s'annonce quand même de mon point de vue
très difficile pour les Argentins
Michael Madar vous qui êtes justement
ancien joueur du PSG lequel alors Messi
on voit on dit qu'il a du génie Messi ou
Mbappé une comparaison
[Rires]
pour moi pour moi il y a pas photo donc
moi c'est les filles
vous pouvez pas comparer une personne
qui achète ballon d'or et une personne
qui a rien gagné à part le trophée
collectif même si c'est la Coupe du
monde mais si c'est cette Ballon d'Or
c'est pas rien quoi ça fait 15 ans que
ça dure ou 20 ans donc Mbappe c'est un
très grand joueur mais ce n'est que le
début quand il aura assez de Ballon d'Or
on pourrait éventuellement comparer mais
pour l'instant c'est pas comparable pour
moi maintenant
parce que 2010 c'est Iniesta qui devait
avoir le Ballon d'Or et ça ça a été pour
moi une déchirure totale donc pour moi
je dirais 6 parce qu'il faut le donner
je le donne comme ça officieusement à
Inesta non on peut pas les comparer
parce que même si le football et le
sport collectif le plus occupé
c'est la guerre des étoiles on les
oppose mais il faut quand même parler
d'équipe et l'équipe de France sur le
plan collectif est quand même légèrement
supérieur l'Argentine après la vérité du
terrain est tout autre on verra dimanche
ce qui ce qui lancera il y a une légère
supériorité mais on verra ensuite ce
qu'il en sera dimanche et c'est deux
joueurs mais si on peut pas on peut pas
comparer
il joue comme Maradona
ils sont pas vraiment dans les mêmes
registres on parle de quoi là on parle
effectivement de deux étoiles qui
s'affrontent mais qui vont pas
s'affronter directement elles vont
s'affronter à distance ces deux étoiles
là donc on verra à la fin du match qui
va pleurer et qui va lever le trophée
qui va rentrer dans l'histoire peut-être
pour Mbappé avec ses deux Coupes du
Monde ou Messi qui va enfin leur
emporter cette Coupe du Monde c'est ça
mais là pour l'instant il faut attendre
dimanche soir au bout de 90 minutes
peut-être 120 minutes après les tirs au
but on en sait strictement rien mais les
comparer aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
comparaison comme on dit n'a pas raison
vous savez Stéphanie
je pense que le vrai gagnant dans
l'histoire ça va être le PSG ça va
surtout le Qatar parce que derrière
c'est deux joueurs sous contrat du PSG
et donc quel que soit l'issue celui qui
va tirer profit de ça c'est le club
et puis ils sont propriétaires a
fortiori dans une coupe du monde où la
finale se déroule à l'oussaye à côté de
Doha donc on est vraiment dans quelque
chose de très intéressant parce que ce
qui joue c'est certes la rencontre du
passé et du futur de de stars qui sont
absolument incomparables sur le plan du
jeu mais c'est aussi derrière tout
l'usage par le Qatar du football et
c'est ce qu'on voit là parce qu'il en
manque un c'est Neymar on aurait pu très
bien l'avoir à la place de Messi vous
êtes d'accord amical Madar vous qui a
joué pour au PSG
[Musique]
Paris va avoir un mois un champion du
monde c'est une certitude donc ça c'est
une bonne chose pour pour le Paris
Saint-Germain voilà donc
on aurait pu voir aussi au cinéma
malheureusement
ils sont fait éliminer un peu bêtement
contre contre ces Croates mais ça sent
un moment donné il fallait bien qu'il y
en a un qui soit qui soit éliminé c'est
ça a été le bonus le Brésil
malheureusement il faut pas oublier il
faut rajouter à Kimi aussi dans
l'histoire puisqu'il est dans le dernier
carré le latéral marocain droit qui est
aujourd'hui à son poste est le meilleur
au monde et effectivement Jean-Baptiste
a complètement raison c'est à dire que
le pog aujourd'hui peut dire nous sommes
le plus grand club au monde puisque nous
avons deux finalistes dans notre club et
nous avons également un Kimi qui était
dans le dernier carré sans oublier une
marre qui était dans une équipe
exceptionnelle mais qui n'a pas passé le
cut donc aujourd'hui nous sommes le plus
grand club au monde ça ils peuvent être
l'affirmer à la lumière de ce que nous
pouvons voir et constater aujourd'hui de
l'actualité de la Coupe du Monde Cédric
oui je voulais rebondir sur la
comparaison Messi Mbappé donc il y a
effectivement l'aspect sportif tout ça
mais ici le ressenti pour vous donner un
petit peu l'oracle on sait de joueurs la
popularité penche clairement du côté
Lionel Messi quand je vous dis ici c'est
en discutant avec les habitants de Doha
notamment beaucoup avec les chauffeurs
de taxi du coup ils connaissent très
bien Lionel Messi quand on leur dit
Kylian Mbappé ça paraît encore un joueur
inconnu pour eux alors faut le prendre
faut le prendre quand même avec des
pincettes évidemment on parle quand même
d'une star internationale qui vient
Mbappé mais est-ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que dans ce rapport entre
Mbappe qui a gagné quand même une coupe
du monde et MBC qui a gagné ça de Ballon
d'Or et qui a dominé le football mondial
pendant quasiment 20 ans maintenant non
20 ans j'exagère un peu les 15 ans c'est
pour vous dire que il y a quand même
encore une étape à franchir pour qu'il y
a une bâper pour se hisser à la hauteur
d'un joueur de Lionel Messi on a
beaucoup parlé des Bleus silver
qu'est-ce qui caractérise cette équipe
Argentine Lionel Scaloni lui il dit que
Messi est le plus grand joueur de
l'histoire qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
va être compliqué dans ce match France -
Argentine
c'est à dire le le la force qu'on les
Argentins c'est un peuple qui aime
vraiment le football et d'ailleurs il y
a qu'à voir le nombre de supporters qui
se sont déplacés à Doha les Français ils
seront 3000 supporters dans le stade je
pense 50 à 60 000
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable qui
reste finalement sur place il reste sur
le place et ce qui est dingue ce sont
des gens qui ont pas forcément le sous
qui ont vraiment cassé la tirelire pour
revenir soutenir l'équipe c'est à dire
que c'est vraiment un peuple de football
le football est dans leur culture
contrairement à la France parce que la
France est pas un pays de sport
un peu ça progresse mais on le voit en
tout cas avec ce qui se passe là et ce
qu'ils ont c'est la grinta c'est le
soutien qu'ils ont à l'équipe ce qu'il
croit en football c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont des gens qui peuvent parler de
football mais des heures et des heures
ils vont pouvoir s'affronter s'engueuler
se disputer à propos d'un joueur à
propos d'une équipe ce qu'on fait
beaucoup moins ça compte ah oui ça
compte parce que ils savent qu'il y a un
soutien et eux-mêmes sont comment dire
ils sont bouleversés il y a de l'émotion
ils sont poussés par une émotion quand
il joue au football c'est à dire qu'ils
ont une mission une mission pour le pays
grande mission pour leur culture ils ont
une mission pour leur foi le foie la foi
dans le football et dans leur sport il y
a un vrai héritage c'est l'Argentine de
kempêche en 78 c'est celle de Maradona
c'est aussi ce rapport à l'argentinité
et ça ça dit quelque chose si vous allez
si vous si vous demandez à quelqu'un ce
qu'est l'Argentine la première réponse
c'est le football et c'est cool alors là
on a découvert l'Argentine avec le foot
le visage du football aujourd'hui et de
l'Argentine c'est Messi et puis lui il a
il a un fardeau c'est Maradona Maradona
est parti aujourd'hui le vide c'est lui
qui doit l'occuper il a gagné une Copa
América ça peut être un fardeau dans le
sens
une véritable motivation et quand on
voit là le niveau de Messi sur cette
compétition on retrouve le Messie il y a
deux trois ans il est en train de monter
oui c'est incroyable il est en train de
monter où j'ai lu Michael Madar qu'il
avait changé mais si
il est vraiment il est en train de
monter il devient étincelant comme des
champs a dit de lui qu'il était
étincelant
depuis le début de la saison avec ce
qu'il fait au Paris Saint-Germain et ce
qui fait en équipe nationale il est
instant il a retrouvé un certain niveau
mais bon moi je m'inquiétais pas trop
parce que pour un joueur comme ça qui a
passé presque j'ai pu 17 ans ou 18 ans
au Barça
en ayant vécu presque toute sa vie
d'adolescent et d'adulte en Espagne du
jour au lendemain partir dans un club
qui est le Paris Saint-Germain et
découvrir une autre culture d'autres
joueurs et une autre façon de voir la
vie et de voir le football c'est sûr que
je savais qu'il y avait un temps
d'adaptation pour pour ce genre de jour
même pour ce genre de joueur maintenant
vous avez bien vu c'est adapté pendant
une saison et à l'heure actuelle il est
redevenu le meilleur joueur du monde
donc l'équipe argentine justement en
dehors de Messi parce qu'on parlait des
Argentins pour moi leur point fort c'est
pourrir le match voilà
encore et j'espère qu'on tombera pas
dans le panneau parce que même si c'est
une équipe qui m'a quand même contre la
Croatie qui m'a impressionné c'était
quand même un beau match avec un avec
deux attaquants qui sont Alvarez et
Messi qu'on fait le travail je trouve
que voilà il y a certains joueurs comme
de pôles ou par edès qui quand est il
voit qu'ils n'ont pas le dessus sur leur
adversaire oui c'est un peu l'atmosphère
et l'ambiance du match et j'espère que
on se laissera pas influencé parce que à
partir du moment où on se laisse
influencer on sort un peu du match et
eux par contre il reste concentrer
jusqu'à la dernière minute Cédric ils
peuvent pourrir le match
c'est peut-être les spécialistes les
meilleures spécialistes au monde pour
pourrir les matchs on l'a vu dans la
rencontre entre les Pays-Bas et
l'Argentine ou la deuxième mi-temps moi
je qualifie même ça de honte le
comportement des Argentins c'était
insupportable c'était à chaque contact
des roulade un an plus finir des
contestations contre l'arbitrage Leandro
Paredes qui doit jamais finir cette
rencontre
mais
on est en Amérique du Sud c'est un
comportement qui est parfois loué et qui
a fonctionné en tout cas lors du match
contre les Pays-Bas on a même vu
d'ailleurs Lionel Messi c'est nerveux
sur le terrain et même ensuite après
dans les couloirs du match qui est assez
rare donc il y avait quand même beaucoup
de tensions et c'est pas forcément très
glorieux du côté argentin mais ça
fonctionne en tout cas ça les motive et
ça motive aussi les supporters ça les
met dans leur camp donc ça aussi c'est
très important vous parliez de l'émotion
tout à l'heure c'est un critère
essentiel pour l'Argentine mais
attention à ce que cette émotion ne
devienne pas trop importante et les
déstab
[Musique]
aussi sur le terrain on a vu par exemple
le match de l'équipe de France les Bleus
auraient dû bénéficier de deux ou trois
cartons jaunes en leur faveur on est
vraiment dans cette dans cette logique
là les équipes vont mettre la pression
aussi sur les arbitres dans les jours
qui viennent avec une communication très
ciblée en demandant à être respectée
vous allez le voir tout le tout toute la
communication des Argentins sur le fait
que l'arbitre est pas allé assez loin ça
va dans ce sens là cette partie là ça va
être aussi un poids pour l'arbitrage
pour la FIFA parce que tout le monde dit
que il y a une volonté de favoriser
aussi l'Argentine de Messi à cette
petite musique aussi dans l'air on
l'entend alors évidemment
c'est loin d'être une évidence mais ça
existe et ça va être intéressant de voir
comment les Bleus qui sont plus jeunes
vont réagir c'est là où les gens les
plus expérimentés Griezmann au premier
chef va être en charge justement de
calmer la meute et notamment à Kylan
Mbappé qui va être à mon avis sur motivé
et qui n'aime pas qu'on lui donne des
coups il y aurait aussi qui va être
important aussi ça
peut être important alors je disais que
Michael Madar je lisais que
Griezmann c'est le sens du sacrifice
c'est comme ça que vous pourriez
qualifier qu'il est même pour devenir
coach sur le terrain
c'est assez incroyable ce jour parce que
voilà Hiroshi pas il est toujours en
train de faire les efforts il calcule
pas
son partenaire perd un ballon il est là
il essaie de récupérer même si il est
pas bon sur le terrain même si il rate
des choses vous pouvez pas lui reprocher
qu'il ne mouille pas le maillot c'est
voilà c'est vraiment l'exemple type et
si les joueurs français prennent exemple
sur lui pour cette finale honnêtement je
me fais pas de souci du tout
malheureusement on a deux trois joueurs
qui sont offensivement ils sont pas trop
d'efforts et les
trois devant mais bon après ça se
comprend aussi moi j'étais attaquant on
a du mal à faire les efforts les
attaquants
c'est pas notre
donc on essaie de se consacrer plus à
aux tâches offensives mais c'est vrai
que dans le football moderne le football
d'aujourd'hui vous n'allez pas le choix
en tant qu'attaquant il faut défendre il
faut y aller aider son partenaire sur
son côté quand on joue sur un côté et je
trouve que on sait pas on l'a passé en
tout cas suffisamment lors du dernier
match contre le Maroc c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi qu'on a pas maîtrisé notre
sujet ça en fait partie donc voilà si à
partir du moment où tout le monde se
comporte comme Antoine Griezmann pendant
cette finale je vois pas pourquoi on la
garderait pas parce que je trouve quand
même qu'on est on est supérieur à ces
argent quoi Cédric alors qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que serait une finale
idéale
mais final idéal pour l'équipe de France
je pense il faut marquer très tôt dans
la rencontre on a vu que les équipes qui
ont eu le plus de difficultés dans ce
tournoi c'est celle qui ne parle des
favoris évidemment au coup d'envoi c'est
celle qui n'arrivait pas à marquer
rapidement dans ce match et qui se
heurter à notre équipe qui est plutôt
été attentiste je pense que c'est un
scénario comme ça qui va se répéter
c'est à dire que l'équipe de France va
faire face à un bloc argentin assez
compact il va éviter de prendre des
risques par peur de Kylian Mbappe la
plupart des équipes confrontaient les
Bleus leur principal crainte c'était
écrit en Mbappé sa vitesse donc ça sera
d'ailleurs le premier souci à résoudre
pour les Argentins s'ils arrivent à le
canaliser et bien peut-être qu'ils ont
une chance de s'en sortir mais si Mbappe
sera le Killian Mbappé des grands jours
pour les Argentins
silver la finale idéale la finale idéale
comme l'a dit Cédric c'est qu'on marque
le plus rapidement possible mais moi ce
que je trouverais intéressant
alors je vous ai dit deux
pour la France allez je vais tenter ce
pronostic là mais tout le monde se
focalise et comme je vous l'ai dit sur
Mbappé mais moi ce que j'aimerais bien
c'est que par exemple un Dembélé de
façon à ce qu'il a fait contre le Maroc
parce qu'il était un peu perdu contre le
Maroc mais qui se retrouve en finale
parce que quand ils se retrouvent
Dembélé c'est un juste un joueur
extraordinaire et qui puisse mettre le
feu afin qu'on ait vraiment de de de de
depuis de folie qui viennent inquiéter
les les Argentins c'est à dire Mbappé
d'un côté d'un bébé de l'autre avec un
Griezmann que je trouve très rassurant
vous savez quand Ngolo Kanté a été
déclaré forfait une fille là on perd un
grand ça va être très difficile et en
fait Griezmann il remplace un peu Ngolo
Kanté c'est-à-dire que c'est la sécurité
sociale c'est une assurance vie il nous
apporte cette assurance dont on a besoin
et quand vous avez un joueur comme ça
sur le terrain vous savez vous jouez
avec un joueur comme ça vous savez que
vous pouvez compter sur lui et qu'il
sera là dans les coups durs c'est pour
ça que Griezmann est intéressant
alors il faut que Dembélé se retrouve
très rapidement et que muppé nous donne
quelques coups de folie je pense qu'on
pourra de avoir quelque chose très
intéressant vous avez un pronostic vous
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on arrive en tête
à la mi-temps on sait que
statistiquement si les Bleus arrivent
avec un but d'avance à la mi-temps il
gagne systématiquement leur match donc
l'objectif ça va être ça je pense qu'un
ça peut paraître raisonnable
on prendra forcément des risques on
s'ouvrira forcément au contre argentin
et quand même de grandes chances que on
puisse défendre nos chances et tout va
jouer aussi sur le rôle de Dembélé et
sur le banc on l'a vu hier que le moisi
tu rames aussi il y a quelque chose à
apporter on a des jeunes qui vivent
assez bien l'événement on l'a vu lors du
match lors du dernier match ça va jouer
aussi là c'est la capacité sur à partir
de la 60e minute à faire entrer d'autres
joueurs capables de prendre le lead et
de faire la différence j'avais dit
Guégan pardon excusez-moi Michael Madar
votre Pronost
je suis pas trop pronostic
un gros à 0
à gros à 0
[Musique]
merci en tout cas
merci d'avoir été avec nous Cédric
Ferreira vous étiez avec nous en direct
du Qatar Michael madame merci à vous
merci Sylvain Henri merci Jean-Baptiste
Guégan et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis nous allons bien sûr suivre
ce match dimanche sur France 24 les
réactions avant les réactions après
alors restez sur la chaîne reste avec
nous
[Musique]